日々今日 h ちょっと経っちゃっちゃーありがとうございます今日も1日が終わろう
としております
午前2時半です
じゃあ
静岡と東京を行き来する回数日本第7位肇社長でそうみんな長距離の移動をどれくらい
したことがありますもちろんわかる長さんが枯れ気味で白ばかり中学旅行といったこと
あるよね
中間額はわかるし卒業旅行は家族旅行は信仰に行う前に旅行とかでよく頭ですよね
大きな伊野尾字
考えられるのは出走お仕事されてる方は出張部活やってる人は冷静とかあるよね
ぽ結構出張低下の静岡にも大内刈東京に大内刈りその行きかすごい多いんですけども
移動で欠かせないもの
それがスーツ系普通つケースなんですねえっつっつけど黒子素朴
データを使っているのはこれなんですけどはいえーと日もりー
日も詫びもうあのスーツケースいつも使ってますなくしてもすぐだ作業になくだついて
ますねまぁ静岡東京行きするとき新幹線道を呼ぶ使うんですけれどもこういう感じで
スーツゲートこう頃転がせば大きな荷物も楽に移動できると思ったんですけどもう
ピラー夜中には
児童についていく
5ケースがあるみたいなんです
買いましたそれがこちらでちょっとあの未知の世界ですね玉で10万円超えてたら
10万円超えてなんですけどもうなんか
スーツケースてた作ったんっも違ってコロコロついてくる奴なんですけども次世代の
スーツケースは沿いのなくて自動で付いてくるらしいんですよそれかこれねちょっと
開けてみたいと思います
[音楽]
いきまいそう納税地だった
持っておりが早い登場だ達増3結構スーツ着てパッと見何の変哲もないスーツ消す見え
ますね本当に大丈夫ですか
なんかネットで見たときも普通に俺があ上での後ろに線つけてついてくるんですよ
どんなもんかなと思ったんですけどパッと見
など普通だしてもいい
これ後にちゃんと持ち手があるそれでして家で持ち馬を超えてたからな相当高いです別
このケースみたいなと反らせていただきますね
はいはいはいはい見たやすげーかっこいいです
床についてくる要素あるけど
兵を出てきた8普通に考えて充電どうかがないと撮影を行いバックですよねこれで少し
マイナー
を開いたねこれはこれ日本じゃないなでもやはり普通のスーツケースではなさそうです
ねスマートスーツケースって書いてあります
めっちゃっぽいはスマートキャリー型
ねええええマジで n
コントローラついてるんですけどこれスーツケースを操作するらしいですますなぜ何か
を持っている簡単そうだと全然荷物を持って入りそうなんで安心しました
手で何かを持ち運ぶ分にはすごいたくさんはいりそうね半分以上がバッテリーとが咲く
てよかった
じゃ早速セッティングしていきましょう
のん
あ青く塗っ釣ったんだけど院マークあるんですけどもこの犬ボタンを押すと
整備ボードになるらしいですこれで一応追尾機能は付いてるはずなんですよドン
ここがんしっ
ん
[音楽]
これ
あっはぁんっ
追尾ということはうわーっ供給に合わないでしょ普通
候補の周りをクルクル回っても
このが武具ついてくるんですねはーい本当にお前
ヤバイぞ危険だぞ実用化は早かったカードマナー普通
ねだから他の手術芸ずに抗議しちゃいけない
はい多い5 e 著
泣きたくて来てくれるもう愛はっちゃじゃない俺税等も若干標本を感じますこれは犬
もうぞ
恋
路床車おいで
頭地ですねそうです元に当たっちゃうとちょっと可哀想だなぁ
水やきれいな道だった2いますが来てくるんですよ
はいうん
一食いたいか言いたいから
ああ
危ないからあっはい
あでもやっぱり色々とねーつい事故は書いてありました人が多いところや交通量の多い
場所で使う夏用取る床によって追尾できない場合がありますいう大変急な方向転換が
できません前の日にはモードとの接触には十分注意してください間違い体にプロフに
小さいことがいたらまず危ないヨッパ広い場所とは人が少ないところで行くのが面倒に
なったときに使うぐらいの機能
熱っ
ん
待てマジでらはーい説明書で行くとゆっくり走るもう撮って帰ったり前に行くんじゃ
ないか
怖いよねか3年のスピードはですけどこれが今ゆっくりめのスピードです
アマナナナナナマってこれがスピード中です
いやもう受注でも相当速いというそしてこれが最初娘とです
a
待って待って濡れ女怖いですから見てて売っ
をせねばならずキロぐらいまで運べるて外だったこれまた乗ってを移動できるように
なるんだよ
マジじゃ
[音楽]
いぇあどこに向かったぜ俺ほどがこれどしょっかなぁ
えっこれ
[音楽]
これ便利か
えっ
[音楽]
これ乗るのが正解かん
goo
クールだねこれがお前の正しい使い方け
早速浅間汗から東京なんで最高にクールに出発します
[音楽]
してい
滞在走っ
th
はぁ
[音楽]
padi
ああああああ
[音楽]
まあ結構井戸出る